this is one of the best business models
for the Creator economy what problem do
you think you can really solve for
people right now and I think that as
entrepreneurs our job is just to be paid
problem solvers if there was any kind of
Creator who was Prime for this kind of
business model a YouTuber is in the
perfect position there's never been more
people online or coming online than
there are right now
so while there's never been more
opportunity in the Creator economy to
build a six or seven figure business 99
of content creators still find
themselves broke and that's because
they're missing critical pieces of their
content creation Empire that we're going
to be covering in this episode so I'm
super fired up to be talking to Brock
Johnson who is an Instagram and social
media growth expert for creators and
entrepreneurs he's also one of the lead
instructors and faculty of the marketing
impact Academy and insta Club Hub and
he's going to be breaking down the
elements that most creators do not know
that are critical for making this a
sustainable business and income and
actually going full time in a real way
and so Brock welcome to the show Sean
thank you for having me super fired up
to have you on and you've been on the
think media podcast before but I want to
actually start off with your story and
we can mine a bunch of tips out of it
because today you're a seven figure
entrepreneur at 25 years old
um newly married been married for a
while you already snowboarded 30 times
this year living a pretty cool life
helping a lot of people but back at 21
you earned almost six figures you earned
over ninety thousand dollars in a year
on social media which was is very rare
you know some people for sure have maybe
made a few bucks in affiliate marketing
they've got a little bit of YouTube ads
going they've got maybe a sale or two of
merch or something else they're doing
but there's a Chasm that most creators
don't end up Crossing which is actually
figuring out how to make this
sustainable and that's because they're
missing some pieces so tell us your
story what was happening back around
2021 for you yeah absolutely and
actually let me backtrack and say I
definitely don't have it all figured out
now by any means uh but I'm more than
happy to go back to kind of where I
started when I knew even less than I do
now
um and so my business started when I was
a freshman in college I was a student
athlete so I had books and ball all day
long I had very little free time and I
definitely didn't have the time to get
like a normal typical job and so my mom
came to me and uh I actually reached out
first and was like Hey I know I can't
work a typical job I can't work a nine
to five I need to be able to provide for
myself though because my goal is to
become financially independent from you
and my dad like I wanted to cut that
that umbilical cord and be able to
provide for myself without the quality
of my life significantly deteriorating
immediately and so that's when she kind
of was like okay well then let's start a
business and at that time uh a course
was what my original business was it was
19 so a relatively low price point I
didn't have a huge social media
following
um and in order to figure out what that
course was she asked me what problem do
you think you can really solve for
people right now and I think that as
entrepreneurs our job is just to be paid
problem solvers and so I had to identify
two things things in order to create
this first course and and thus my first
business it was what problem can I solve
and where is there a Gap in the market
or basically what problem needs solving
because plenty of problems have already
been solved so what problem can I solve
that hasn't already been solved and at
that time it's going to sound funny to
say it now Snapchat was all over the
news for the dangers and the beware and
teens are on it and who knows what
they're up to and there's creepy
stalkers on Snapchat with disappearing
messages so everyone was really
concerned about Snapchat very similar to
how they're concerned about say tick
tock nowadays but at that same time I
had just taught my parents how to use
Snapchat as a way to communicate with me
as a freshman in college
um and so I was like well I know how to
use Snapchat I am 19 years old so I'm a
teen I I know what these kids are up to
and so I could make a course basically
teaching how to use Snapchat and how to
keep your teens safe on the app and that
was my my very first business in how it
got started it yeah that's wild and you
know that's probably my favorite
business model is the e-learning
industry Forbes just updated the numbers
that it's going to be over a billion
dollar a day industry by 2025 and it
just continues to explode teaching what
you know packaging it into an online
course and thereby jumping past needing
an algorithm or a platform to pay you
pennies exactly for being monetized in
some way so go a little bit deeper
though what was kind of that initial
launch and how did you build that
business what were some of the elements
needed to package that put it together
and actually get it to Market totally so
of course I needed a platform to house
the the e-course and there's plenty
online I found one that worked for me
that could just kind of house and sell
uh create landing pages for that actual
course in terms of the creation of the
course it was as raw rough bootstrapped
as you can get I rented out a private
room at the local library and I didn't
even have a tripod at the time so I just
leaned my phone up against some books
from the library the angle was like on
the table shooting directly up my
nostrils I hung like a little Banner
behind me which I still remember it was
like crooked very badly crooked um it
even fell down in one of the videos
super rough and I just banged it out for
like three or four days in a row I just
stayed in that room I would bring my
lunch with me and I would be in there
for hours and hours recording as much
content as I could and then eventually
um once I was done with all that filming
I had it sent off to an editor because
very early on I learned the lesson that
I'm not gonna be able to do all this
myself and we were coming up on the
football season so I knew my time was
going to be even more pinched so I sent
all that content off to an Editor to
just be roughly chopped up nothing fancy
um and then it was football season so
then for about six months I couldn't
really do much I couldn't really promote
much and also I didn't want to I wanted
to focus on that current season of my
life once that was over I I got all the
editing back I've added it all into the
course and then it actually became time
to start promoting and launching and
talking about it and that was primarily
done uh on social media yeah that's
amazing and so was that what got you to
ninety thousand dollars or did you have
to add on some other things add on other
things so this is really the the
Difference Maker that initial launch was
not amazing like it was I think we maybe
made two thousand dollars in total off
of that launch which I'm not saying
that's not you know something to be
proud of but also that's hardly even
paying a month's rent especially that
time I lived in Washington DC I
definitely paying a month's rent in
Washington DC I quickly pivoted because
again I realized that there was a hole
in the market and I listened to my
audience which I think is absolutely key
and what I was hearing from them from
all of these primarily moms who are now
learning how to use Snapchat as they
said great well now I know how to keep
my kids safe but I also have the
knowledge of how to use Snapchat and I
have my own business I have my own side
hustle I have my own network marketing
company I have my own real estate
business I'm trying to grow how can I
use this new social media Snapchat to
leverage it to to grow this business and
this was something that I was actively
doing doing because while I was teaching
people how to use Snapchat I was also
encouraging all of my students to join
my community on Snapchat and start
interacting with me so I had in building
my Snapchat for parents business
accidentally built a business and a huge
knowledge base of how to use Snapchat
for business and so I quickly pivoted
within about six months of the initial
launch and kind of stepped away from the
Snapchat for keeping your kids safe
angle and rebranded in Snapchat for
business instead of teaching other
business owners how to grow and Market
on Snapchat and so that's how I
transitioned from the first course which
was I think about 19 during my initial
launch in the second course which was a
lot more knowledge based there's a lot
more packed into it and also it was also
for a different clientele so it wasn't
for parents just keeping their kids safe
it was for business owners and so this
was something that I charged a little
bit more for I think it was maybe fifty
dollars or fifty Seven dollars for that
second course and that launch was what
got me a lot closer to this 90 000 mark
that I hit in the first year yeah that's
amazing and again for if you're
listening to this the question is what
do you know that you could package into
an online course that solves a problem
for somebody this is such a cool
industry because yeah there's some
expense in software and there's some
skills to learn but because it's a
digital product your shipping is easy
refunds are easy and any kind of
customer service support is easy and
fulfillment with the tools that are out
there do you remember what you used I
know that inside of the marketing impact
Academy you I think review lots of
different tools because it's like
thinkific and teachable and kajabi and
different options do you remember what
your original one was it was originally
kajabi that was my first one yeah and at
think media we've really built like our
whole business on kajabi some people say
what is the best and it's it's kind of a
platform war between these there's
kartra and there's new ones showing up
and there's pros and cons to each of
them but the key is you definitely need
a vehicle to package it into a way so
you can sell it and take payment and I
know that's kind of overwhelming we'll
talk about some resources later
regarding that but you know what's
fascinating about this is
I want to highlight when you kind of
figured out Market message match and if
you could you figure it out too you
thought okay well if it's business
owners if I can help somebody make money
get customers get leads grow their
business that is a you can charge more
for that too because of the result that
it's going to deliver what's fascinating
is we got to talk to Miss excel at
Social Media Marketing World she's
teaching Excel which if you can connect
your course to how it could make someone
more money in this case you get a
promotion you come in with Excel skills
she came out of corporate she's got 100K
a month business selling Excel and
Microsoft Suite courses a lot of people
are teaching different uh JavaScript
type stuff or coding but then also a lot
of people teaching homeschool how to get
started if people are teaching like
beginner Bible study courses and whatnot
for somebody that wants to dive into
Theology and whatnot so listening to
this what do you know that you could
package into an online course this is
one of the best business models for the
Creator economy and the cool thing is
you also don't need a huge audience to
potentially generate some serious money
the two thousand dollars you earned is a
lot more than a people who stay stuck
just hoping they go viral hoping that
they you know get a zillion views and
get paid a few pennies for that nothing
against YouTube ad revenue or all these
other options but you're really taking
your business Destiny into your own
hands in this regard by packaging what
you know into an online course so what
are some of the biggest mistakes that
you see you've got 639 000 followers on
Instagram at the point of doing this got
it you also have talk about some other
things that you're doing you've got two
side projects you've got a YouTube
channel that's kind of a passion project
yeah but you've also got a YouTube
channel that's kind of surprising that's
generating some decent money on the side
what's happening there yeah so uh those
YouTube channels they're really fun one
like you said passion project my wife
and I we do a lot of Vlog content just
kind of documenting our life we were
talking about the other day it's just a
great uh almost like a video diary and
we're gonna have it for years to come
eventually one day if we have kids then
we'll be able to show them these videos
and make them sit on the couch and watch
this was your mom and dad 15 years ago
but then we also have our dogs YouTube
channel which is just essentially
repurposing content from her Instagram
page taking her YouTube or her Instagram
reels repurposing them into YouTube
videos and sharing YouTube shorts and
that Channel's blown up and that's super
effective and we're now starting to get
into brand deals and relationship with
other dog influencer companies to start
working on the actual income stream from
that side and then I also have my own
YouTube channel so I guess I actually
have three YouTube channels and my
YouTube channel is just kind of another
iteration of what I share on Instagram
which is social media growth tips and
Instagram strategies and that sort of
thing but the way I got here and the way
I got to 600 something thousand
followers on Instagram 300 000 something
followers on Tick Tock it wasn't
overnight definitely and it was also not
all at once it was one out of time it
started with Snapchat and when I was on
Snapchat I was working really hard
posting dozens of Snapchat stories every
single day I got up to over 10 000
followers on Snapchat back in like 2017
and that's what I was using to grow my
business but at the time Tick Tock
didn't exist it had just been named
musically and was bought by bite dance
like there was no Tick Tock yet there
were no Instagram reels I was barely
posting on Instagram I definitely wasn't
posting on YouTube I wish I would have
um but I just got started with one
platform and then I grew and I pivoted
and I evolved and I'd let my interests
take me in different directions I
brought in more staff but all these
things were one at a time nothing was
you know all done at once people can now
look and see like wow he's got all these
different channels and all these
different accounts with thousands and
thousands of followers but what they
don't see is that I started on YouTube
with like basketball trick shot videos
and creating content in that way when I
was like 11 years old so now I now have
15 years of experience creating content
trying out different businesses
rebranding pivoting and changing and so
it's taken a lot a lot of time a lot of
effort a lot of dedication and
consistency to get to where I am today
that's encouraging too because I know
people are at different stages in the
journey and so hearing that this isn't
overnight but one of the things I want
to highlight is oh in just a second I
want to talk a little bit about the
biggest mistakes people make the
building blocks of actually getting away
from being dependent on algorithms or
just being a broke Creator but getting
some of the pieces that people are
missing but I want to highlight
some of our listeners
are passionate about documenting their
life about vlogging about sharing their
story and which I think is amazing but
that is one of the least viable crater
economy businesses in our opinion that
we teach what I actually love is that
you figured out a viable business that
actually funds your passion Pro projects
it is our conviction at the think media
podcast that real artists Don't Starve
we all hear about Starving Artists but
real artists Don't Starve and so that
that now you can do that stress free
because you have this other thing paying
the bills so for some listening to this
I just want to even speak directly to
our community it's like there is maybe
you have your passion but you're torn
because they're all also might be
something practical and there might be
different brands we always encourage
people figure out the brand that is the
shortest path to revenue because then
once you've got cash once you have cash
flow
you can then fund your artistic projects
as opposed to saying I'm just going to
have a vlogging channel so maybe like
flipping your thinking and the
sequencing of your events you guys just
went snowboarding 30 days this season
Mammoth is having crazy levels of snow
so you're saying that you can go
multiple more you guys just uh got
approved for an offer on a house in Park
City you are able to live this great
lifestyle but it didn't happen overnight
and it didn't happen by picking the
wrong vehicle first yeah the basketball
trick shots video as well so that didn't
work out but but even but it it was it
happened because you saw what were going
to even go deeper into in just a second
built a real business yeah website
funnels the thing need you know need
around that product package which you
know got all those things in place but
that was the unlock that opened the door
to the life you're living and to then
put staff around it virtual assistants
around it help around it so also being a
pet lovers you can have that channel as
well and even fun you're essentially
funding other business you're that what
is your dog's name Mila Mila could
actually become a decent brand you
should get some brand deals she's
starting to become that herself and that
may that might be the first thing you
start with but if you're listening to
this maybe not so even the sequencing
can't do everything at once but if you
do the right things in the right order
it could be the door that opens up to to
launch all your creative projects over
the next two three four five years
absolutely and I think like you said one
of the biggest challenges or the biggest
mistakes that a lot of early creators
make new creators will will stumble on
is knowing which to start with which
step to do first what to create first
and I loved your point about picking the
the path to revenue quickest what's
going to get you to making money the
fastest maybe not what you're most
passionate about maybe not what you want
to do for the rest of your life but
what's going to be able to make you
money so you can get the ball rolling
where are the quick wins to be found
because if you are consistently you know
chasing your passion project but there's
no income coming in there's no Revenue
you're not able to keep food on the
table then it's not going to last very
long it's going to be a really draining
experience where instead if you start
from a place of I'm going to take care
of my basic needs which in the world we
live in a basic need is you need some
sort of income you need some sort of
money to to be able to afford these
passion projects this art whatever it is
that you truly want to do and so to
bring this back to my own story I wasn't
passionate about helping moms keep their
teens safe on Snapchat I wasn't
passionate about
um you know teaching people how to grow
a business on Snapchat it was just
something that I learned to do and I was
good at and I recognized that there was
a gap in the market that I could fill
and now I've grown and I've
built these other passions that I can go
more into and I can make Vlogs of myself
snowboarding even though I know that
those are going to be the absolute worst
performing videos on my YouTube channel
I can have the freedom to take a few
hours and edit my own snowboard video
and pretend I'm Travis Rice and post it
on my YouTube channel it'll get 200
views but I'm fired up about it and I'm
only only able to do that because I
entered the pain cave early on and I
embraced I embraced the suck and I
embraced hey I might not love doing this
but I'm good at it and there's a market
for it that's really really strong so I
want to talk about the marketing impact
Academy and then we'll talk about uh a
lot of tips we can learn for the
foundations of building our business
social media strategy but this episode
is uh brought to you by Mia bonus.com
and again full transparency years ago
I'm trying to remember when I want to
say around 2014 or 15 I became a student
of the marketing impact Academy this
program changed my life you now co-run
this program as one of the instructors
with chalene Johnson your mom and I had
the opportunity of originally doing an
interview with her even doing some
freelance video for her and then I got
exposed to this world that changed my
life because as a tech YouTuber YouTube
ad Revenue was earning a few hundred
bucks once I kind of got to scale and
Affiliates I started to by having people
click affiliate links talking about tech
I was able to earn a few thousand and
that brought me to six figures but what
skyrocketed our business to seven
figures which to also make this
practical you know oh well Sean you've
been doing this for a while you knew
video or well yes but also like your
story it took a decade to learn all the
skills and invest in online courses and
my learning and myself and my education
imagine if you just did 10 of seven
figures I'm not even very good at math
that's 100 Grand I think so yeah imagine
just a five percent it's an extra fifty
thousand dollars I mean you did two
thousand dollars in your first course
whatever just the practicality of
packaging what you know in an online
course figuring out how to do that and
then figuring out the 52 things I didn't
know of eventually like well how are you
even gonna make the offer well how do
you even structure an offer how do you
even put together a webinar and I
remember in these early days of think
media I was watching the marketing
impact Academy on my phone on a
treadmill at Fitness 19 in Las Vegas and
and wild story because now Omar El
takori is one of our content creators
we're in his Studio here in Vegas A lot
happened since then he came in and we
actually re-got connected and I was like
Hey Omar crazy to see you here he's like
what are you doing I'm like I'm studying
I'm trying to learn the skill set of
creating an online course and learning
how to Market it and learning how to
brand and all this different stuff and
uh then we started to make videos and he
was a video editor all that to say is
every year and it's actually been I
think a couple years since we've even
talked about this we have let our
community know about this program that
changed our life we only like to share
programs we vetted you know work with
brands or companies that we vetted but
people can know that we are students of
this program and what's kind of cool is
we've put together some specific YouTube
trainings that are separate that are
just extra because you guys recently
opened the doors to the marketing impact
Academy so without going further into
that if you want to check that out it
said Mia bonus.com and you can see
everything in the show notes but give us
an overview of what this is and let's
get into some value about the things
people learn inside of the marketing
impact Academy totally so I told you my
story earlier of how my mom was really
the one who guided me in starting the
Snapchat business and to give you the
the full background story I was really
homesick I was really struggling I was
opposite in the Country California is
where I grew up Washington DC is where I
was going to school and so I called my
mom crying one day and I was like Hey
like I just need you to come visit me
like I'm feeling homesick I'm really
struggling so she flew out and we stayed
up in her hotel room until like 2 or 3
A.M making this business plan working it
out figuring out all the different
pieces what needed to go in what order
but unfortunately she's not available to
fly to every single person who is crying
to her on the phone and meet with them
and stay up till 2 A.M in their hotel
room so that's where the marketing
impact Academy comes into play and
essentially what it is is it's more than
just a course and that's why it's called
the marketing impact Academy because
it's truly an entire entire business
school but imagine you show up your
first day at college and they just hand
you every book that you're going to read
for the entire duration of college they
hand you every syllabus and every one of
your professors is just standing there
smiling you're going to be extremely
overwhelmed and not know what to do and
so what I think the the unique value is
that Mia provides is a step-by-step
blueprint of here's the order that you
need to go in but there's still
everything else you could ever want to
know so there is YouTube lessons
provided by you there's Instagram
lessons provided by me there's Facebook
there's email list building there's
website design there's branding and
marketing and Pitch deck all of these
things that can feel overwhelming if
you're just kind of dumped on your lap
but instead there's a step-by-step
Playbook that's actually going to walk
you through here's day one here's day
two here are the fundamentals of
actually building a business not just
getting views and crossing your fingers
hoping that you go viral and get a few
pennies for every you know couple
hundred thousand views that you're
getting but actually building a
sustainable business and then how do you
build this other side hustle and this
other stream of income and this other
side hustle so you can you can chase
Your Passion projects and you can do the
things that truly bring you Joy you
don't have to stress so much about where
the next paycheck is coming from or
where you're going to you know find your
next customer yeah I love it and being a
student I know that you continue to
update the curriculum and change it some
of the elements that if someone wants to
build uh 50k 90k multiple six figure
seven figures that I that I took away
was I think first getting clear on your
audience I think a lot of people listen
to this they may not even really
understand who their person is yeah I
learned the term lifer from you guys and
it's kind of another way of saying
Avatar although you do think about it
differently and I think if you think
about it better and you go into that
that's first getting absolutely clear
and this will help you just in the
content creation but then in the product
creation clear on who it is that you
serve what prom do you solve then also
list building 99 of people probably
listening to this right now are are
doing it wrong because they are
disrespecting email marketing oh my gosh
yes it's pretty wild speak on that yeah
absolutely it's shocking it's scary
honestly to see how many people put
their faith and and all of the
proverbial eggs in the social media
baskets which ultimately in this Web 2.0
world that we live in we are operating
on rented territory we don't own our
subscribers we don't own our followers
we don't own the access to them
algorithms are always changing platforms
might get banned they're always you know
changing their features and so it's
getting tougher and tougher and tougher
not even to mention increased
competition to reach our quote-unquote
followers it's so challenging but an
email list is something you own it's a
way to contact people that doesn't
require an algorithm it doesn't require
this third party uh you know mediated
communication through Instagram or
Twitter or whatever and so an email list
is absolutely essential and to speak to
your point about knowing your avatar
knowing your niche as some people might
say a lot of people you'd be surprised
think they know their Avatar they think
they know their Niche and we recently
did a study 97 of our new incoming
students who believe that they have
identified their Avatar or they know
their Niche they know what their thing
is they actually haven't fully done so
they haven't gotten deep enough they
haven't gotten specific enough and so
that's step one that's step one for
growing on social media for building a
business that's absolutely essential and
97 of people not only don't have it but
think they have it and they actually
don't yeah no that actually isn't
surprising to me and it might be
listening to this that might be a hard
pill to swallow because what can happen
is we just get we get too far down the
road we do fall in love with our topic
which fine you could do what you want
but it's not a guarantee that's going to
be successful what's cool is you and uh
chalene Johnson Brett Johnson chalene
and Brett have been mentors in my life
for years now was so fortunate to be
able to do video production for them you
know I think maybe as early as 2013 2014
and all these different quotes and
different things that they've taught me
have been absolutely life-changing but
when people are uh trying to start a
business you want to learn from someone
who's done it been there done that and
as mentors I don't know what the number
is but they've built multiple seven and
eight figure businesses like five or six
or seven you know what I mean in Fitness
in physical Goods in digital products in
the health industry in other Industries
so even reverse engineering back this is
my one of my favorite words these days
is viability if you don't even get your
step one right you don't get your
foundation right what everybody gets
into is like you guys are buying a house
and probably one of the things that's
most excited uh exciting is is even
thinking about decorating it Furniture
what TV are we going to get what art are
we going to put up but if the foundation
is off on your house yeah or if even the
roof and the walls and the structure is
compromised then all that cool furniture
and all that cool artwork is going to
get soaked when it starts to snow and
rain in Park City yeah and that's what's
happening to a lot of people they're
like how do I get more you know views on
my reels or my YouTube shorts or how do
I just you know get people more engaged
in the comments that's like step 20 and
going all the way back to not just
getting your foundation right but
viability from the start knowing am I
going to be creating a product that'll
actually sell will this fly will this be
something that actually works out if you
get that right then you start building
your list then you actually have to
shoot it though package it promote it
name it then you have to actually build
out
a process to host it online what are
just some of those steps obviously we
can only cover it at a 30 000 foot level
here in this conversation but once your
online course is done what are just a
few of the pieces that you then have to
do next yeah and so these are definitely
things that are covered and I love that
you mentioned like will it Fly because
our good friend Pat Flynn who wrote that
book He's also an instructor inside Mia
yes and so earlier I mentioned this
analogy of like you walk up on your
first day of college and all of your
professors are there in front of you and
that's similar to what it's like in
M.I.A and that there's not just myself
and my mom there's also as I mentioned
earlier yourself Pat Flynn and dozens of
other industry experts because I
recognize I can't be an expert in
everything and also as an entrepreneur
you either have to turn to these experts
like yourself like these other uh you
know people who are well versed and have
been doing these things for decades to
learn or you have to try to become the
expert yourself which is an option but
it's oftentimes going to be one that's
going to include a lot more headache and
frustration and take a lot longer
um but in terms of actually the steps to
building a business first and foremost
like we've already talked about you have
to know that Avatar you have to know the
topic the niche the sub category who are
you specifically trying to address and
even getting it so specific that you
have one individual person in your brain
I think of one of my friends from
college his mom like that is the exact
person I'm thinking of when I'm creating
my content when I'm designing my courses
when I'm building my business once you
have that we have to of course then go
down the route of how are you going to
get this product or is this even going
to be a product an e-course what is the
actual offer going to be and then we
need to go about getting customers which
most people think is social media the
only way but there are actually a lot of
other ways that we cover in Mia that
don't require going viral and twerking
on Tick Tock and posting 19 YouTube
shorts per day in order to go viral and
just reach a giant quantity of people
but all of those things are absolutely
taught
um and explained in depth in the academy
yeah and and I'm leaning heavy on
digital products online courses because
it's one of my favorite business models
but there is at Mia live there is people
you learn from there was a sea shells
person is that Shopify who's doing
jewelry what was that story yeah yeah I
remember that story she um she sold I
think it was some sort of like seashell
jewelry yes which I feel like it's a
tongue twister and she was selling it on
Shopify yes uh Sally sells on Shopify
with the seashells yeah
um and yeah she has a six-figure
business just on Shopify and she's
selling this custom handmade jewelry and
I don't think she has a huge social
media following at all in order to build
this business yeah and so the the cool
thing is marketing impact Academy you
got to learn marketing online marketing
branding positioning and and these best
practices that 99 of craters are are
missing because we do we just fall in
love with the front end content yeah and
that's when social media gets fun is
when you have a back-end business that's
built So eventually got to upload the
course there's all these things that
seem overwhelming but that's why it's
nice to have someone to show you step by
step in a and a group of people and I
also do want to speak specifically
because so many people are part of video
ranking Academy already which is our
signature YouTube course this also if
you're part of video raking Academy this
is the next step this is also a good
first step but a lot of people in video
record Academy ask us constantly how do
we learn this next set of skills how do
I build an email list how do I package
what I know into an online course how do
I upload that market that promote that
how do I build out the sales sequence
how do I build out the
um different pages that you need and
then the payment processor and connect
it all together and to your point just
like people who made the smart move and
invested in video record Academy of
course you could try to go it your on
your own and become an expert on all
these things but that is the worst way
because it's uh so slow it's just gonna
take you years if not decades and you
can compress time if you value your time
you just take the paint by numbers uh
process and and again when I was
launching it I was just shocked because
I was like every time I would get to a
thing like okay now I want to eventually
create a web class and if someone's
listening to the think media uh podcast
right now you've probably seen one of my
web classes one of my webinars would be
kind of the old school term we like to
call them web classes or master classes
there's masterclass.com or whatever is a
popular brand and so we're just always
trying to use the language that people
would understand it's a free online
class about YouTube which is one of the
things that we would let people see and
then let them know about our YouTube
course at the end like even how you
structure that class you could sit down
and just try to wing it but instead I
just painted by numbers that those web
classes just followed I think what's
called an MIA is the infomercial formula
yep and life-changing I've watched that
thing like 10 times yeah and then I just
just was like okay so this would be the
structure and then of course I filled in
my knowledge and my understanding about
YouTube but even also storytelling I
mean there's too many rabbit Trails I
can take right now and all these
critical components and storytelling and
learning to craft your story I know
you're deeply passionate about
storytelling you have a storytelling
book and you think about these stories
and how they illustrate the business so
anyways
um I have a couple final questions for
you but I want to back to speaking to
video record Academy this would be your
next step like I want to encourage you
if you're listening to think media
podcast you're part of era at Mia
bonus.com not only do we have some extra
things that we're including during the
when they open the doors to Mia it's the
best business model for YouTube content
creators especially that are in
education and you know one of the things
Brock that's interesting is I um was at
Social Media Marketing world and I
talked to the course creator platforms
teachable thinkific they had some staff
there and we we got into a conversation
and they said our most successful course
creators using our platform are
YouTubers and I said the reason why was
because if 65 percent of people are
going to YouTube
to solve a problem or ask a question
their your discoverability there which
the whole promise of era is the is the
opportunity to get found get discovered
and build no like and Trust in a free
environment right where they're watching
for YouTube videos but then people have
also what's already happened between you
and them is they've already decided oh
like I kind of like this person's Vibe
oh this person's been helpful and then
if you're able to be like hey if you
want all the things all in one place
like I also have this course available
and it could be anywhere right kajabi or
udemy which we don't really recommend
but it could be anywhere and you know
ultimately that's it becomes the one-two
punch because I I think that this should
be a piece of almost everybody listening
to this at some point should create an
online course it's just such a great
asset even if it's not your main thing
and you lean heavy in other directions
you know teaching how you did what you
did or to your point getting inside of
the marketing impact Academy and just
going through the process of unearthing
some things you don't even know yet
totally you don't even know what you
don't know yeah totally and there's so
much of that in there and I also think
speaking specifically about YouTube
creators is from a technical standpoint
they have those skills to create the
videos create the audio create that
course it's essentially the same thing
as making a YouTube video the only thing
is it's put in a specific strategic
order and it's put behind a paywall
that's the only difference really
between an e-course and a YouTube
channel even the the playlists on
YouTube YouTube are very similar to what
you would be offering inside of a
e-course and so I think that if there
was any social media or any kind of
Creator who is Prime for this kind of
business model a YouTuber is in the
perfect position I totally agree and you
know another reason to uh some mistakes
to avoid is some of the things that
people avoid a lot though is or need to
avoid is wasting their time on things
that don't work working on the wrong
step in the wrong order but also
potentially
avoiding a lot of lost revenue and as
you mentioned that YouTube is trying to
get into the course game basically they
are are now adding on platform
integration of content behind paywalls
to equip creators to package what they
know to either a part of Channel
memberships where you can do exclusive
content just for your channel members or
there's some new features YouTube
premium all of this other stuff big
warning to people listening to this is
YouTube is uh like the mafia kind of
when it comes to some of these features
because they're taking like 30 so
imagine you build a six-figure course
business in a year a hundred thousand
dollars you're gonna give YouTube thirty
thousand dollars crazy and so also
having product comparisons of these
different where you like all these
little details matter because when you
take the shortcut to just get good
information and good education you know
the difference between thirty thousand
or thirty percent five percent or no
percent as are some of the platforms you
just do the math and these could be the
difference makers to having a lot more
money in your pocket viability so we've
covered a lot so I want to give one one
final question for you in just a second
would be just your parting advice for
Content creators and entrepreneurs that
want to increase their revenue and and
some parting words but just to be clear
on exactly what's happening we wanted to
get this episode to you think media
podcast
um because again once a year the doors
open to the marketing impact Academy you
can go to
www.mia
bonus.com and that's of course in the
show notes and just check out all the
details out there again you know how
choe we are uh we just love to share
with you programs and products that have
changed our life this has now been a
community we've been I've been on trips
with uh Brock and chalene and Brett
they've spoke at our event I think like
every single year chalene Johnson you've
spoken her event like two times and so
you may already be familiar with uh this
kind of community maybe not all the
details for the extra bonuses that we're
doing uh that we're offering during this
time are at Mia bonus.com and in this
show notes and we just believe in this
program wholeheartedly and it's simple
it's pretty simple because it's changed
our life and it has actually made think
media what it is today we have the
front-facing content creator thing going
and that's what I was able to figure out
but I was lacking the back end business
building Brick by Brick online business
you know mechanics that are all broken
down beautifully and a whole lot more
than that as the academy continues to
evolve so uh this all this of course is
limited because they only open
enrollment
um you know for a limited time so check
it out that's all in the show notes and
uh Brock I want to ask you though final
parting words of the opportunity you see
right now for making a living in your on
your own terms maybe being able to quit
your nine to five Be Your Own Boss and
just advice for Content creators
um when it comes to this yeah I think my
my final piece of advice would just be
to be bold enough to bet on yourself you
know I'm reminded of kinee quarter who
left her corporate job she's an MI
student left her corporate job and is
now the world's number one financial
hypnotherapist and that was done because
she was willing to enter the pain cave
she was willing to embrace the suck but
she knew how to do it in the right order
so she was willing to make the jump but
she knew where to jump right like if I'm
picturing myself uh you know climbing up
a rock on the edge of some Lake and I'm
gonna jump in you need to jump because
that's where the difference is going to
be made but you got to know where to
jump you got to know how high you got to
know where what's the direction to head
in and I think that that's uh what I
want to encourage these entrepreneurs
the these video creators to start
looking for and I think that that's
hopefully something that we can provide
for them is the where to jump but
ultimately be bold enough to bet on
yourself and rip off that Band-Aid
because there's never been a better time
in human history there's never been more
people online or coming online than
there are right now I know there are a
lot of industries that might feel
saturated or feel like oh I I miss them
a mark on that the only way that you
missed the ship is if you never actually
try to get on so yes one has left the
port but there's another one leaving
right now and there's another one
leaving tomorrow you need to get on and
you need to to jump in the water so to
speak and rip off that Band-Aid step up
to the plate I feel like we could give
endless analogy shoot your shot you know
there's a swing the the bat there's a
million different uh analogies we could
give for this but ultimately you need to
take that first step you need to be bold
enough to to bet on yourself I love it
Brock Johnson of course we'll link up
all of the stuff we've talked about this
limited offer with our bonuses and all
of this in the show notes but you're
also creating incredible content on uh
Instagram and you've got some YouTube
channels uh shout people out if they
want to connect with you Brock 11
Johnson across all social networks
that's where you can find me Brock thank
you so much thank you